hey guys have some training footage from
my first real workout back from Asia
who's over there doing some seminars in
Kuala Lumpur Malaysia and in Singapore
so back in the states now and serious
training is resuming once again this is
495 on a triple for squats I did two
sets here my program moving forward for
the next few months is is going to be
kind of built around pushing the volume
and frequency trying to get some work
capacity back because it's absolutely
terrible right now so you know I need to
to build back up that base before I can
do the type of training I need to do to
keep moving forward my wife's on the
same program as I am there she was
demonstrating darn near flawless squat
form and this is 305 4 4 on bench fairly
close script not very much like Drive
trying to you know get a robust training
effect without beating my body up with
heavy weights did four sets there and
then moved on and finished with some
pretty light deadlifts just trying to
get my groove back there it's been
pretty inconsistent lately now the
program I'm on now I'll be putting it in
an excel sheet pretty soon and it will
be available to download for free I'll
let you guys know when that's ready
here's my dog Oswald if you follow me on
Instagram or Facebook
I'm sure you've seen a lot of this
little guy before he's the best dog in
the world this has nothing to do with
training just just thought you should be
aware that my dog is much better than
yours and is probably the thing I missed
most while I was in Asia but now getting
to the really important part of this
video these beers the guy you see across
the table that's my dear friend Kevin he
was visiting from out of town and we
were actually splitting two beers
we had the 'la trap quad on
it's good in the bottle but it's one of
my favorite beers to drink on tap and
they're the the black hole you see in
the middle of the table creating its own
gravitational field sucking everything
else into it that is the heavyweight
champion of barrel aged stout it was
fantastic
there to the left you see the Isidore
Belgian strong Pale Ale Lindsay was
drinking that then Kevin's girlfriend
was drinking some gluten-free beer I
honestly don't remember the name but
yeah that was those were the beers and
that was the training and thank you for
watching don't forget to Like and
subscribe thanks guys